hey what's up guys my name is V Turner
and welcome to episode 21 of network
chat programming okay so two things that
I want to do today first of all I want
to kind of change around the way that
we're kind of doing things I don't know
that's kind of a big deal sounds like a
big deal it's really not but right now
what we have going and this isn't what I
would normally do but I just haven't
given this much thought I guess we've
got this client class yeah clientele
Java and in this class we've got two
things that I don't like well I guess
we've just got two different worlds in
one class and that's kind of not a good
thing in a way so what we've got going
on here is we've got both the behind the
scenes kind of backdoor backends a
client to server connection stuff and
then we've got the front end kind of GUI
interface thing and it's not really a
good idea to combine the two it's I mean
there's no reason to combine the two so
it's better to split them up okay and if
we do split them up which is what we're
actually about to do it will become much
much more apparent it'll be much easier
for you guys to see the two different
worlds the world of the GUI and
displaying everything to the interface
and the world of the server
okay well but by the server I mean the
client so the world of the the world of
the networking that the client handles
all the networking methods will be in
their own class and everything else like
this what is it like the the set the
send thing will be in its own class as
well okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna just right click here on
Cherno chat and we're going to go new
class I guess we're gonna create a new
class we're going to call this one
client window
okay I'll client interface you can call
whatever you like I'm just gonna call
client window this is gonna be the
window of the client okay obviously
obviously our main method is gonna be
copied over there so it's actually not
even here it's called login okay oh
that's another thing okay then so main
the main method is in login cool so over
here you can see that we make a new
client rather than doing that we're
gonna make a new client window alright
and then the window in turn will create
its own client so that makes sense the
window the interface handles
the GUI stuff right so the window which
is the gy has its own actual back-end
so um that's fine so let's go ahead and
go into a client I'm actually just gonna
close all these server server main
server client unique ID fi all this
stuff that we don't need close and just
leave the stuff that we do need open so
um we'll just grab the entire thing over
here
and we'll just cut that so this'll this
episode well the first half at least
will involve a lot of kind of
refactoring right so like copying and
pasting changing name stuff like that
and I believe that it extends jframe so
let's go ahead do that and then another
big thing is the client itself should
not extend extend jframe there's also
will allow people to have multiple
connections which is good so in other
words you could have multiple taps up
and which connected to multiple chat
servers if you so please this create
window method clearly has to get cut all
this stuff like there's no point having
all this in in in like the client with
well along with amongst the client
networking code like that just sounds
weird
so let's import all that you can see we
just imported about 50 things let's go
back just hit command shift over there
by the way I'll ctrl shift o if you're
on Windows and we'll grab so let's say
over here so we pretty much all of this
okay so we've got this is nicely divided
actually I divide this pretty nicely
we've got these the clock the networking
stuff and then we've got the interface
stuff so we'll cut the interface stuff
and we'll paste it into here so that we
get our J panel and everything else we
need all about text fields and then open
connection above course stay in open
connection will of course stay in the
client class so we'll receive send and
okay so console weren't and send warrant
actually as well because sand actually
calls this send method which is the real
sand method but this is that send method
just allows us to sense of things if we
went with that we'll go over here and
paste that into here wunderbar as
wunderbar as the as the German folk
would say now we've also got stuff like
name address and port I'm actually gonna
leave that in here and you'll see why in
a minute instead of setting this name to
name this not address to address when
I'm doing any of that stuff we're just
simply going to pass that along to the
client that we create in a minute here
now let's say we don't have any errors
in here so I think we're done so we've
got a little bin force here that we
don't need you can see they're all
highlighted in our in in like they're
underlined in yellow here if you you can
delete them manually or you can just go
a command shift o again or ctrl shift on
Windows and as you can see that will
just sort everything out so that's
eclipses organized imports thing if
you're using another idh you have a
similar thing of course now let's get
into this I hope that now woke you up
that peeked really really high on my
little audio recorder here but um what
we're going to do now is create a client
right so this is a client window in fact
we got to change the constructor name to
client widow to client window okay and
so we've got all this stuff here and you
can see this reference is a lot of
method from the client alright so we've
got something like this and a method
here which sends the attempted
connection thing we've got we've got
this opening connection but all this all
this thing so what we need to do here is
of course create a client so a client
window will have an instance of a client
okay private client client and this
client of course will lint will enable
the window to crash so what we need to
do is when we do start this thing the
first thing we should do is go ahead and
go client equals new clients we're
creating a new instance of the client
with name address and port okay and then
we can get rid of this alright and let's
see what that's giving us so misplaced
constructs of course I've forgotten this
let me calm put it in the wrong place
like an absolute novice alright so
there's we actually have an American
store ok we'll remove the constructor
that's probably not good so let's go
ahead and create a constructor so public
clients string name string address and
in port
I'm gonna be pretty lazy here and just
simply copy some of these things so I
think let's see that stuff the
connectors opening connection that's
fine okay that's pretty easier than
isn't it okay so all we need to do
is all we have to set up with that
socket and the unaddressed thing but we
all but basically let's just go ahead
and go ahead and say this dot name
equals name this dot address equals
address equals address and this dot port
equals port all right and then with that
let's see all right so an open
connection now we can just simply type
client dot open connection okay and I
think that method is private so okay
we'll have to go ahead and make most of
these things public here so copy paste
the public pretty much everywhere okay
keep the fields private though over here
in this same thing we can go ahead and
call client I'll send I'm just checking
to see if there's any actually important
of now what do we actually create this
so client I'll open connection so open
connection okay open connection is what
actually creates the socket as you can
see now I'm just thinking that might not
be the best way that you have this like
entire thing here well leave it as that
for now because we kind of design it
that way you could put you could move
the open connection into the constructor
for client that's by creating a client
you're actually opening the connection
but so we'll keep it as that for now
just because that's the way it is that's
the way the cookie crumbles so name okay
this is where we have to make a few
methods in clients so what we have to do
is make a nice string a getter here
so public string it get name okay and
this will of course as you can probably
imagine return the name ok we'll also
make public string I get address which
will return address I'm not sure that
why why we will use that but we do need
public int get port which will return
port okay well I guess I guess we could
be returning the address for if we just
wanted to like debug or if you wanted it
just print messages to the console so
send we changed a client dot send name
we change to client dot get name and I
don't think I think that's it okay so we
don't have any errors anymore a bunch of
warnings here
we have to make sure that we implement a
default serial ID you could do a
randomly generated one we're gonna need
that
let me sending this anywhere we're good
okay we should be good I'm just quickly
seeing through this so to test this okay
let's just go ahead and go on a server
and we'll just start a quick server here
if you go into the server main and you
run that I'm gonna drag this up so you
guys can see a bit better so we've set
we've started a server on that port
brilliant we're gonna go into login and
run that and of course that's gonna
bring this thing up so we'll type in
yarn for the name localhost
and 8 1 9 2 let's hit login and we'll
see what happens you can see we attempt
a connection
it looks like the server has received
our connection here and it's received
our name is assigned and identifier for
ourselves if we go ahead and say
something hey you can see that this gets
relayed back to the client does it works
and also the server prints the address
so clearly it's receiving some kind of
packet here ok that's it I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode I'm actually gonna
cut it back because it's like 10 minutes
long already if you guys did enjoy it I
would appreciate it if you would hit the
like button below because that lets me
know that you guys are enjoying it of
course that makes me happy next episode
were propagating cover I guess a
verification that the client has
actually connected right now we don't
see anything the client doesn't we see
in attempting a connection we don't get
any kind of confirmation to that so that
should probably happen
and after that we'll probably actually
work on adding more clients and stuff
like that so I hope you guys enjoy this
episode of don't share programming and
I'll see you guys next time goodbye